this cyber monday the online shopping
day where you can throw away all the
money you saved at the stores on Black
Friday and congratulations by the way to
those of you who survived Black Friday
that capitalist spectacle where shoppers
from all walks of life come together to
spread holiday cheer and punch their
fellow man in the face for a
kid's toy like these thrifty customers
Wow look at those savings his life is
half off he's these poor SOPs traveling
one another like spooked Buffalo to get
a deal on electronic panini makers this
is this is an American tradition you
guys but what about our neighbors to the
north check out this video posted by
Suzette Beliveau this is how they do
Black Friday in Canada Oh
see these these polite consumers they
may not have died in a mall but they
will meet their end years later being
gored by a moose while drinking the bats
over an ice fishing hole or as Canadians
call that natural causes so comedians
what are some announcements you would
hear over the PA at Canadian Black
Friday Pizza homes hi Chris
hi Pizza how about attention Canadians
if you're out of cash don't worry we
also accept cheque credit card firm
handshakes eye contact and tickle
Generosa Canadians let us all enjoy this
peace while it lasts because America
will be attacking us very soon because
president Trump has a tiny tiny tiny
tiny penis
also clean-up on aisle a come on you
guys never be welcome back in Canada
again hi attention Canadians $50
healthcare you sign up for healthcare we
give you $50 yeah